cloud.
All right, welcome back everyone uh to
another episode of AI Networks. Uh this
uh I'm Bibb, one of the creators of BAML
and with me I have
>> uh my name is Dex. Uh and I'm the
founder of Human Layer.
>> Yeah. Um
>> 12 factor agents, although VIB doesn't
get enough credit for that one.
>> 12 Factor agents and you want to give me
a shout out, give Vibbob a shout out,
too.
>> Uh no, that's all good. Um but I think
today what we want to talk about is
really around a topic that comes up a
lot. Uh which is we have new models come
out all the time. How do we actually go
about measuring which model we should
use? Should we swap the model? Should we
not swap the model? We're going to write
some code. We're going to show you how
to do it. And then but I think most
importantly we're going to we're going
to start off with just a general
discussion around this uh really quickly
and I'm going to try and get like people
to share their thoughts along the way.
So the first thing I want to talk about
is like for everyone that is um that
does build LM applications um you can do
by show of hand type in chat whatever
you think is best.
Uh and Dex as well like I want to ask
how many of you are how many of you did
when you see a new model come out
immediately go back and try and update
your prompts to use that model right
away.
>> Steph you do
>> uh yeah I've done this a couple times.
Um,
even back like a year and a half ago
when it was like GPT4
switched to GPT40, that was the biggest
one. That was and like I know 40 was a
little bit dumber, but it was so much
faster and cheaper that I was just like,
"Okay, this is faster. We're good." Like
I vibed it in 30 seconds. I was like,
"Yep, we're going to use this one from
now on."
>> I see. And like what drives that for
you? Like what is it just cost for you
that makes that decision? Like what?
>> It was speed. It was experience. We had
we had a thing in the UI. Basically, we
we built this app before we were working
on human layer. We're doing this thing
like analyze uh SQL queries from your
SQL audit log and like pump them through
GPT and then like summarize the query
and then like segment them by person or
by table to try to give descriptions of
like what is this table generally used
for or what is this person generally
query things about. And so that summary
was like take the last 10 queries,
summarize those and then do that a bunch
of times in parallel and then summarize
the summaries. And so like we had to we
were running a ton of prompts and so
like I think 40 is like four times
faster or twice as fast as GPT4. So it
was a huge like UX boost because we were
doing it live on the fly. We hadn't
started like pre-filling it or warming
the cache for it or whatever. So it was
like the speed was the only thing with
like user experience. It was like this
is faster even if it's slightly dumber I
want it.
>> Yeah. I think that's normally what I've
seen as well. Uh it's like if there's a
huge step function improvement, most
people are just immediately trying to
swap over at least some of their prompts
to the latest model or at least see how
they could do. But at least my empirical
evidence has been the minute a uh the
minute um like a new model comes out,
the first thing that I often see people
do is like wait for other people's
response to it and
>> let someone else vibe check for you,
right? Yeah,
>> that's what I feel like I'm seeing a lot
more of is like people are like mostly
happy with the model today or they're I
would say like it's like the known enemy
and a new model is like the unknown
enemy. It could be good, it could be a
friend, but you really don't know and
like the effort of actually seeing if
the model will work or not work is not
worth it especially if a system isn't
broken. Well, and what you see also is
people come up with their own uh like
benchmark systems like their own um how
do we say it like their own just
personal benchmark of like when a new
model comes out I have a bunch of
prompts that are secrets that is like my
private benchmark set that gives me a
feel for how it performs and I can tweak
and like see how that works. Um, if
you're an AI engineer, this is a really
good talk. Simon Wilson talks about his
benchmark for seeing how good a model is
is now like his vibe is generating an
SVG of a pelican on a bicycle and like
literally generating the SVGs from
scratch. And so like he has it for Nova
and Llama 3.3 and Deep Seek and kind of
like how all of these different models
draw things.
>> So like this is not a technical
benchmark. This is a vibe benchmark, but
new model comes out, he's running this
test on it basically.
So that as well.
>> Yeah, I think um I think that's kind of
what I see too.
>> Sorry,
>> we got some comments in the chat as
well.
>> I think Sylvia put um Sylvia said a
point about like this is uh the best way
to do it is just like prompt it.
Honestly, I think I I feel the same way.
Like for example, we have our AI content
pipeline that we use to summarize these
videos, send out emails, send out little
blurb. We'll probably be adding pretty
soon to it. will be adding this ability
to
uh what I would say is like add um
hopefully add like blog posts written
about it as well from the same context
and our borrow
>> I wrote a pro I wrote a prompt for
tweets based on it it's pretty well
>> yeah and it's surprising it it takes a
while but like now that it's working
would you change to a new model
>> the original owner was kind of
>> oh I'm not a host I can't mute people
for you
>> I don't know why you're not auto host
let me make you an auto host.
I'll make host. There we go. Um, yeah.
What what would you do like now that the
tweet pipeline is working and the other
systems are working, would you go ahead
and like update the model?
So, here's another thing that's happened
recently is like and this is going to be
kind of like uh
sorry, I lost my power for a sec. Um,
we built this whole pipeline and then I
was like prototyping something in
Claude. Um, and just seeing like we
built this pipeline to do the tweets and
the human a loop and all this stuff. And
I jumped in. I was just like, can Claude
build this in like a headless like the
more agentic way?
>> Yeah.
>> Um, and so that's the other thing. It's
like not just vibing different models,
but different like architectures.
>> Um, let me see if I can switch back to
the other. There we go.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, but this tweet, this LinkedIn post
here was literally entirely written by
Claude. Every I didn't edit it at all. I
added the credit for the slide because
Claude can't do links. But like this is
from our last episode. I just said I'll
show you the prompt that we use. Um
it's called social. So it's like find
all the whiteboard images and the
episodes. So if you go on our website um
this is getting a tiny bit off topic,
but um this is exactly kind of how I'm
vibing through this stuff. So here's the
episode and it's basically like for each
of these pictures that we uploaded like
download it look at it and write a post
about it.
Um so like use will get to download the
image create a Twitter post that
captures the key insight keep it short.
Each post should teach one specific
lesson from the whiteboard and this is
the file that got created. So it
basically for each one um yeah so here's
the one that was posted on LinkedIn. Um
so this is kind of like it's not just
vibing like
one prompt in and the model does
something but it's also it's like how
smart is the model at like multi-turn
tool calling and stuff like that. So all
that is to say is like not only should
you say here's the text in here's the
prompt what comes out this like like
tokens in tokens out context engineering
view but also like can you zoom out like
is the new model smart enough in the
right harness some kind of like just
like simple tool calling loop like cloud
code to solve a bigger problem to like
oneshot a LinkedIn post or something
like that.
>> Yeah, exactly. I think that's the right
mentality and I think the really like my
my approach to new models is honestly
twofold. whenever I think about them.
The way that I approach new models is
one I every time a new model comes out I
try and like flip the switch in my brain
that helps me like think about what a
model can do and cannot do and just like
turn it off. It's really important I try
and remove that bias because otherwise I
won't ask the model to do enough and I
just push the model to its limit. I try
and use a shorter prompt that is maybe a
little bit more ambiguous sometimes even
and just see what the model does and
then I let I run like 20 or 30 of them
and then I get a vibe check on how good
it's going and if it can do harder
problems it's a more interesting model
if it behaves better in certain domains
it's a more interesting model and if
that is true then only do I go and say
like okay now let me go and see how well
this model performs on the actual task I
need to think about
>> in your like production code in the
product you're building
>> exactly and I usually will never ever
think about swapping a model until I've
built that intuition on my own. And if
if it seems like tangentially
beneficial, what I view it as, it's not
worth the energy that it would take me
to go do that and make the system
slightly better when I can just make
when I can just go ahead and add a new
feature cuz it's not about like whether
or not you switch the prompt. switching
prompts takes almost as much time as
actually writing a new feature usually
because and it's not even because you're
like doing busy work just that writing a
feature now is really fast because you
can use a genic system to write code but
evaluating evaluating an AI pipeline is
always going to be really slow because
most people don't have automated evals
so what we're going to do is vibe evals
and if we're going to do vibe evals
we're going to be slower inherently
along the way and that's what I often
see as the bottleneck
when I go and like uh decide what I do
and don't do with these systems. Well,
and and I'll I'll link this talk as well
is um Ben Stein from AI engineer talked
a little bit about what it's like to be
a product manager in the AI world where
you're doing a lot of he doesn't call it
like VI evals from like a engineering
perspective for him it's a little bit
more like the the properties are
emergent and so we can go build a new
feature and pull in a new model and then
put it in our product and then goes play
around with it in the context of the
product and see oh it can do this and it
can do this and like by playing and
trying and like exploring it then you
back into oh that's a cool feature we
want to build for that if it since it
since now we know it can do that let's
now we bake the evals now we do the
testing but this idea that used to
happen Ben put it as like we used to
have this idea of like behavior driven
development where like non-technical
people would write the specifications of
like in this case it should work like
this and in this case it should work
like this and we would like it was like
given when then if you've used like
cucumber or girkin or anything like that
it was like less technical people would
write this Englishy syntax and then the
engineers would develop that and like
the take is like that doesn't work
anymore in the AI world because it's
really hard to be able to say we must be
able to do this and then like oh the
models can never do that but if you just
throw the new model into your product
and see what can it do now you're like
oh it can do that okay cool let's go
make that part of the spec. Yeah, with
that let's jump to the fun part of this
uh session. Um, which unless someone has
someone else they want to share, but it
sounds like most people have the same
opinion as us, which is like they
usually uh evaluate one is like should
we even update? If the system is
working, don't update it. If you want to
try the new model, then you kind of end
up vibe evaling uh along the way. With
that, let's talk about how one does vibe
eval because I think that's going to be
quite important um to actually think
about it. So, I'm going to screen share
uh my desktop. Again, as always, if you
see something you're not supposed to
see, please let me know so I can turn it
off and clip it out of the screen share.
Um otherwise,
>> do a do a poll real quick because I just
fixed your generator versions.
>> Oh, thank you.
>> It was cursor hallucinated a generator
version, but
>> unless you just pulled it down.
>> I did. I just pulled it.
>> So, the prompt that we're going to use
is actually uh the AI that works prompt.
We're going to go ahead and try some of
these, especially like the email prompt
to see like how do we actually eval the
email prompt? Today we use the Gemini
um model to go do this. So like is there
a way that we could perhaps see if we
can use the non-geemini model to do
better?
>> And this is yeah, this is something I've
been really curious about especially in
the context of like BAML because BAML I
think is my for these low-level evals of
just like does did we if we change the
prompt are we gonna break things we know
are supposed to work? Um, but I've never
really had a good framework for like I
want to just take this one prompt and
test it with the same data across four
different models and like see what that
workflow feels like. So, I'm really
excited to have you dig into this.
>> Yeah. Well, like I think the first thing
is like obviously we can deal one model
at a time. Oh, did I not set up uh
one second, I didn't set up my end bars.
Um, I went to hide this and then set up
my environment variables.
Um while you're doing that um let me
just check the chat here. Um Jud says
we've been testing and validating
results of one model against another
model mostly for the batch ecosystem
setup not real time. So there are places
where I or my team are quite occupied to
even review the results which are
sometimes hallucinated. We try to
automate validation results from one M
model again. Yeah. having one model look
at the outputs of other models is like
technically in an academic sense uh I
think is uh corre like papers will say
that that works better and LLM as judge
works like improves your accuracy but it
also is like that same thing that the
the postwe point is like the more steps
you add to your pipeline the more you're
introducing uncertainty and so if your
judge is just as inaccurate as your
other models then you uh may end up just
having creating more like stochastic
effects and more randomness.
>> That's true. Um the challenge we had was
mostly in the batch ecosystem and we
were like just lazy enough to review
like I mean to give you guys some
context we do like large reports on
candidates and when we do that it's
painfully st I mean we we had some
hallucination effects from open AAI or
any standard models we were like tired
of it. the we put them in like some sort
of a recursive loop in our ETLs and uh
that somehow saved us a lot of time
because now we have near um uh near good
level accuracy meaning both the models
are trained very differently right like
llama 3 or open AAI or anthropic so that
kind of helps wet the results for us but
this is not really uh related to this
topic I just thought I'll throw that out
there yeah I know you guys are talking
about evals of one single model yeah
That's a actually um that's actually a
really good question that leading into
like what is accuracy and like accuracy
can be hallucination rate. Um I'm just
going to pull up one more slide that
I'll I'll I'll add to the show notes as
well. Um let me go grab that
um
really quick. This is from a talk we
gave at the MLOps uh meetup um or agents
and prod like virtual conference. Um,
where is this?
I think this is the wrong deck. Sorry.
Let me go find it.
Um, basically the idea that like uh
performance in the past was all about
cost latency like before AI. Um, here we
go.
Um,
like Vibbos says this all the time,
right? Can can you imagine if your REST
API failed on 20% of requests? Like you
would be having an outage. You would
update your savage page, you'd be like
everything is broken. But in an AI, if
it gets it right 80% of the time for
certain use cases, that's like kind of
good enough. Um, and so before AI, we
had latency and uptime and cost and
security, but now we also have accuracy.
And accuracy is like number of
hallucinations and a couple other
things. But like it it's really like
depends on your use case, right? Like in
certain cases there are things where
like oh if the model gets that wrong,
the user will be able to tell and they
can go change it. But there's other
things where it's like if your model is
fetching context from some list of
regulations and you want it to like
accurately
uh reproduce the content of that
regulation in its reasoning trace. That
has to be correct. Otherwise, like your
app is not only like not helpful, but
it's actively harmful.
>> And so, this is kind of when we talk
about performance. Yeah. Go ahead,
Silia. Just to articulate what I think
you're saying, it seems like you're
saying that accur or what I'm taking
away is that accuracy is implied to also
be a a standin for quality and it's a
poorly defined word and it can mean a
lot of different things in a lot of
different contexts,
I guess.
I think that's I think that's valid.
Yeah, I think that's a good way to put
it. And it's like again I'll I'll share
the link to the product talk which is
like accuracy and like trade-offs and
like what you need and like what makes
your product good and like what makes it
what delivers value for the because like
you could say like 95% accuracy and 99%
accuracy from the customer perspective
are equivalent. Like those two things
both help the user solve their problem
in the same way, the same amount. Well,
>> but there are other cases. Yeah.
>> If I'm vibe coding and I have 80%
accuracy, I can just go fix the 20%
that's wrong.
>> Yes.
>> Or like like it's
if accuracy
like in that context, what accuracy
means is makes working code. Um, but
it's if it's hallucination rate on
factual data, that's a completely
different
measure than makes working code. Well,
and I think it also depends on your you
like writing code in cursor is a very
human in the loop experience where it's
like even if the code it makes is not
quite working or doesn't quite pass the
llinter or whatever, it's like you still
saved me a bunch of time even though I
have now I'm just doing 20% of the work
instead of 100% of the work. Um but in
certain workflows like if if if it's
hard for the human to be in like a lot
of these like cloud maxers,
hyperengineers, whatever you want to
call them like their their goal and like
the goal of tools like cloud code which
is totally headless is becoming more and
more like how do we make it so that you
don't have to edit the code or so that
like if if the code is wrong you can fix
it with a prompt rather than with um
something like something like going and
editing the file yourself. an experiment
like he went spent about a month having
multiple different claents prompt each
other just to like see how actually good
that was right now and I thought that
was an interesting experiment.
>> Yeah
like yesterday with like 12 sub Asian
instances and just one container with
two orchestrators and it was not fun to
do that. I think the idea is very very
similar to like for example this email
task. Like what the heck does good
accuracy mean for generating good email
that's a summary for a for a blog post
of some kind. It's actually really
really ambiguous what it would be. Like
for example,
>> if we miss bullet points, if we miss
topics, that's fine. But if the tone
sucks, then we're [ __ ]
>> Exactly. And like and for example, like
hello first name. I don't personally
care about this right now because our
workflow right now is we take the email
that is generated from this system and
then we paste it into loops. If we did
this in a fully automated way then
suddenly accuracy of generating hello
first name no longer works.
Now I need to guarantee that it
generates hello first name and I need to
substitute that with the actual variable
that they swap out in the loops API
system. And now my accuracy constraints
and definition have fundamentally
changed.
So, it's possible that a new model
allows for that, but I think the the
real way to always think about it is
exactly what Sylvia said, which is you
always have to think about the business
use case of AI before defining the
problem. It's like it's when people talk
about like if if you're an engineer or
worked with engineers before, you'll
often see people that are talking about
like how does this work in the case of
um like someone's like, I want to make
the a I want to make the system faster.
But if there's no user criteria attached
to making it faster, there's no end
goal. Code can always be faster. Code
can always be better, but you need
always a definition that makes sense for
the product. So in this case, the email
can always be better. We know that
there's no end to a perfect email. If
there was, marketing would be solved and
we wouldn't have to do any of this stuff
ever again. There'd be one button that
you press and you generate the best
email. But most things that are worth
solving from a business standpoint have
no infinite goal. The thing with AI that
I think makes people more nervous about
this compared to other problems is that
the iteration speed feels faster. So we
feel like we should get to a faster
better solution faster as well. So we
want to converge to the best solution
ASAP. So like when a new model comes
out, I think the feeling that we're
having most of the time is not that this
model is going to generally like oh
maybe this was what I needed, not a
better prompt, not a better software. I
just the model will solve all these
problems and make it go away. And
sometimes that happens. GD4 to GPD35 was
a big difference. Undeniably so. GPT 40
Mini like D said changed latency in an
order of magnitude way. And there's no
five evals that Dex Dex actually said he
will lose a he will lose um accuracy and
like reliability in favor of latency
because that mattered for his product
experience.
On the other hand, DeepC came out and
like the need of it being open source
and matching even if it's worse than
GP40 suddenly got a lot of people
excited because it opened up use cases
that weren't possible before. But if
you're a consumer app that has like
let's say like a 100 thousand users or
like a thousand users and that isn't a
big problem for you, just use GT40.
There's no need to eval.
But I always think it's worth thinking
about. So if you have high accuracy
constraints like in this case, we can
always make the email better. Let's talk
about how we would eval this. Well, the
first thing that we would do is what I
like to do is just very very basically
just like at least have one test. Like I
have one test here and it's written over
here. I want to deal with this. I might
actually have a couple more tests and
let's see if I can get it.
>> But the the idea being like if you have
one test you can just drop in 40 mini
and just like verify your probably gut
instinct that like 40 min is going to
suck at this task or drop in sonnet 4
versus opus 4 and just kind of see how
do these things perform just by looking
at the output.
>> Sorry I was sharing nvar and I did not
want to share it again.
So, right over here, um, we're spending
almost no money because the system's
pretty good. But if I go into here, uh,
what prompt am I on? I'm on email
structure prompt.
That's what I run. Okay, cool.
Let's just make another test cases. So,
I have two now.
Okay, now I have two test cases. And
this is literally a thing from cracking
the prompting interview. That's a
subject. it has this and like dumps out
a bunch of stuff that describes uh
cracking a prompt interview along with
um what the next session is about. Um
and I can just go
>> Okay, cool. So this is So the inputs to
this are the outputs from parsing the
transcript and just asking it to pull
out these four different like categories
of insights.
>> Exactly. And like it talks about labels,
diorization, a few other things. So I'm
not going to prompt I'm not going to
email the whole pipeline. I'm going to
eval just as one step because eval
pipeline is a thing I can do but like
it's way easier to just make sure that
the one step got better and then I can
make the other step go better and right
and the analogy that I always use in my
self is like a long time ago it was
definitely true that most people could
write better assembly than what C could
write but now the C compiler is always
going to be better than most people can
ever write and like systems get better
over time. I think we're in the assembly
era of prompting right now. We're
probably not at a point where like
systems can automatically heal
themselves because not because they
can't do it, but most people don't have
good problem definitions on which they
need to optimize for. So therefore, the
best thing you can do is first get a
good grasp of your problem. So if I just
like go ahead and quickly run this um
I'll run this test specifically
and we'll just see how well it works.
And while I'm doing this, I'm going to
talk about how we can eval multiple
models because I think that's the part
that everyone is really really
interested in. So we'll do from
and I have to
install one more thing. UV run UV add
identic
sync.
Cool. So it is running all the
environment variables are running
correctly. So, I want to see how well
this works.
Python restart language server.
Why is it not picking up?
This is the most annoying thing about
Python. You have to set the environment
variables correctly.
Um, and I believe I have to do one last
thing, which is I have to tell it to
generate.
>> Probably have to generate.
Oh, yeah. I was putting in an app but
>> oh that's okay I'll just put it directly
there. Um and then what we'll do is
we'll do B dot and the test that I'm
making is only on draft email. So like
draft email
and I'm going to pass in some sort of
summary into it and then a structure
uh along with it and then I'm going to
like get the results. At some point what
I want to do is swap the model. So like
let's really quickly make a test case
from this. So I will uh
there you go and then claw fill these
out the wrong thing I
and it'll do its thing. But while it's
doing its thing, I basically have a
result. Now, the first thing I'll notice
is what I really want to do is I'm going
to do the very very quickly dumbest
thing that I can do, which is No, I
don't want this, which is I'm just going
to save this to disk
and I'll just dump the data out and that
will do something for me.
>> You want to put a time stamp in there?
>> Um, I'll do that in a second. Now, what
I really want to do when I go run this
system is actually
Uh end
there.
>> UV addend. Oh
>> that is like the worst naming of any
package ever and I hate it.
Um I wish they would just take end over.
Um and it does this adds this stuff in
there and then prints this out.
Now the real thing that I really really
want to do over here is I want to make
sure that whatever I'm dumping into here
is actually like parameterized over a
lot of test suites. What I'm actually
going to do is I'm going to say
defaf load test
name stir
um
Okay. So, you're going to be storing
your test data on disk as JSON.
>> Exactly. I'm just going to load it and
I'm going to load it into here and I'm
going to go send both the data out of
here. And the reason that I'm going to
go do this is now what I'm really going
to do in my eval set is not just this.
And for now, what I will do is I'll just
like um
Yeah,
>> I'm just going to hard code these for
now.
And did I spell structure wrong?
What did I do wrong?
>> You have an indent somewhere. Oh, your
indent on summary needs to have come
back one.
>> I forgot. I hate Python.
>> Love Python. Best language.
Hey,
>> I set this up for TypeScript, dude. You
could have done this all in TypeScript
if you wanted to.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I will. I will. I
will.
Um, and then what I'm really going to do
after this is I'm going to go and let's
run a bunch of models. So I'm going to
have a bunch of tests and I'll say uh,
and I can choose what dimension I run
this on. I can run it per test per model
or I can run per model per test.
>> It's up to me. And the dimension
>> Oh, I see. So you're going to do like a
nested for loop basically like for each
test run the same test against four
models and then dump them out so we can
look at them.
>> I'll like write all these out. It
doesn't really matter. Um, and I have
some models that I've already defined.
So, like if I go into um
>> Okay. So, you're not going to generate
multiple BAML clients like in the BAML
source. So, you're going to use like the
dynamic client builder.
>> I have some that I'll define over here.
Um, and some I won't. So, I'm just going
to run three model. GT40 Mini. I'm going
to run this and I'm going to run my
Gemini smart.
>> Um, I think I have a different model as
well called my Gemini store somewhere
over here. So, I'll just go to these and
just see what else I I like my Gemini,
which is going to use a flash as well.
>> Cool. Nice.
>> And I'll just put these all in here. I
won't think about it. And I'm going to
run each of these models along the way.
Now, the way I'm going to do this is I'm
going to run like for model in this
client registry
equals client.
I think I see where you're going with
this vibe of are you trying to do like
dynamic passing of the model names by
the client?
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Ah, sorry I'm typing very slow today. I
don't know why.
That client or BML pie right
pie. Yeah.
Sorry, I've been I slept very late last
night, so I'm a little bit slower than I
normally am when I type.
And like boom, we're just going to set
the model. And now we're going to give
the eval of that model. Now, the problem
that I want to want to do here is I'm
going to want to also do this for every
test. So I'll say for test
in this range, and then for this, I'm
now going to go run the test. It's
basically a parameterized test suite,
but there's a reason that I'm not using
pi test.
>> Do you want to move this in here? The
load test
>> based on test name.
>> And the reason that I'm not using piest
right away um is that the way that I'm
going to run this test is actually going
to be async.
So I want to run all the stuff in async
mode.
>> Nice. And the reason I want to run all
of this in async mode is because this is
going to be a lot of stuff. I don't
really want to think about what I run
when I have basically infinite capacity.
So I'm just going to run maximally
parallel stuff.
>> Do you have to change where you're
writing to? Also,
>> say that again.
>> Uh with your with open result.json.
>> Yeah. So it gets tricky when you do
eval. The reason that this gets tricky
is because at some point some of these
are going to fail. You just you just
know that if you're running a bunch in
parallel all the time like model outages
naturally happen. You might put retry
logics in here. You might do all sorts
of things. But at some point some of
these are going to fail. So there's a
couple ways to do this. And what I
always do is I just do this def run unit
u
I always run I always run it wrapped in
a thing
and I always run it this way and I will
also do like the saving and everything
in here right in here as well. So if I'm
going to go save something, I'll save it
in this function directly
and then I will just do a try
accept
and we'll usually not turn
and I will just guarantee that this
function is not allowed to fail.
>> God, I love Python.
>> Say again.
>> I love Python.
>> Yes, indeed. Uh that is how I feel about
this. But I mean, you're going to have
to do this anytime because we have a
high network dependency. And if you're
truly running eval, you're probably
running like 500 of them, a 100 of them
at large test bandwidth. So like you're
going to have to design code. If you're
only running 10, it doesn't really
matter. Just go do it. Um, but if you're
running a lot, this does matter and
starts making a huge difference. So now
we can go do this. We run the unit test
and we go do this. But then we get to
have a the best part is we just have to
have like a tasks cube. now
and our problem goes away.
Uh, and now we have a really, really
nice Wait, what is this?
>> We got to fix this. How you're writing
to the disc or something.
>> Sorry, I'm going to fix this.
>> Nice.
>> Uh, and now this no longer needs to
write to disk.
And then boom.
>> So something needs to write to disk,
right?
>> Well, this part right here. I'll write
to this right over here. I'm going to
write in this method. Uh, this is where
I want to go this, but I don't want to
do it anywhere else. I really only want
to do it here. Now, the other thing I'm
going to run into is all this stuff is
going to run really massively in
parallel. So, how do I want to think
about this? I have to think about what
I'm going to go do. So, I'm going to
have like a target directory.
I think you also need to return from the
run unit test function. It's returning
none.
>> Yeah. Uh I can just ignore that. But I
can just like also return like true.
>> Yeah.
>> Or return false.
And that's okay.
I can
There we go. And this will give me some
modicum of something. Uh,
and it'll be like it'll tell me how many
tests actually pass versus failed. And
there's some count over here. And then
the other thing that I want to do is I
just want to save this to disk. And it
kind of figured it out what I wanted to
go do. So like let's just leave it at
this. I don't want to think about it.
Um, I'm going to go run this. I'm going
to run I'm going to create one more test
really fast um from here.
I wish uh it would just do it but it did
not do it properly. I'll do it manually.
>> I don't think you need the transcript,
right?
>> Um I don't remember what we passed into
this. So I'll try
a long freaking transcript. I forgot how
big these things.
>> Yeah. The whole point of this was like
we were we were showing off how Gemini
can be used with the whole transcript,
but I
Yeah,
I guess you could keep the transcript if
you wanted to. Why did you say you don't
use piest again? I might have missed
that part.
>> Because when I run everything in
parallel, it starts to get tricky how I
want to save stuff, how I want to go do
things. It gets really
>> And like the thing about pi test is it's
like a unit testing framework. when
you're running evals, it's much much
closer to Jupyter notebooks than
anything Piest is going to go do.
>> So it's actually like the better. You
wouldn't use Jupyter notebooks and piest
for the same thing.
>> Yep.
>> And this is exploratory, right?
>> Exactly.
>> Okay, let's have Cursor do some more
work.
One second. We're actually working on
getting exporting test cases to here
because it sounds very useful
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. What the
[ __ ]
>> You said revert, dude.
>> I realized that.
Um, how do I get back?
>> Can you command Z?
>> Can't.
>> Can you undo?
That's gone. Okay.
>> Yeah, it's gone.
>> Oh my freaking god. Sorry.
>> Oh, you could be like that guy that
posted on Twitter about how cursor
deleted a month's worth of your work.
>> Whoa, that was a lot.
>> This is why I don't use cursor anymore.
>> It's like the UX is there's just one one
thing that that there's just certain
times it just doesn't doesn't behave in
a nice way.
>> I thought I accepted the change and
everything. Um, is there a way that I
can fix this? Let me just see.
Same chat. If you didn't if you didn't
run the second prompt, if you just
clicked off, it would have fixed it. But
it's gone now.
>> No, it's gone. It's gone. So, I
apologize, friends. Uh, we're going to
have to wait a second uh while I go do
this again.
>> And Dexter, do you use cloud code for
everything now?
>> I'm using cloud. I haven't opened an
editor in uh in about a month, and I
shipped eight PRs yesterday.
Dex is one of the best um cloud coders
that I've seen. I'm actually trying to
learn from him.
>> Okay, I think we're good.
>> Yeah, I'm uh I'm restraining my uh my
instinct to Okay, so it does have it in
like the edit history, so it can kind of
figure it seems like it kind of
remembers what you were doing
>> kind of. It's almost
>> You lost your end. You lost everything.
Wait, Dax, drop some claw code like
lower while we wait.
>> Once once Vib gets this running, I'll
I'll I'll take over for a second. I'll
I'll I'll whatever the next change we
make once the initial thing is done, I
can I can take over and have show you
some claw tricks.
>> Nice.
Okay. I think we're mostly done. Uh,
this will, I think, work in theory.
>> You lost your M though. You need to get
back.
>> Yes.
Cool. Okay.
>> Yeah, let's try. We haven't run any code
in a while. I'm curious just to like
kind of run the simple version and see
what happens and then we can iterate
from there.
>> So, I have to still migrate these tests.
Um, but I think I can do it in a
slightly nicer way, which is
>> maybe I should have used cloud code and
that was my mistake.
>> It's always a mistake.
>> I don't trust it anymore.
>> Well, it's very also interesting to see
what's going to happen with the pricing
change because I know I'm I went to a
meet up in SF a couple weeks ago that
was like the uh the quad maxers meet up
and they literally like checked receipts
at the door. If you're not spending more
than $50 a day on AI coding tools, then
you don't get in
>> really.
>> And there was a lot of people at that
meetup.
>> I think Cloud said it was like 5% of
their users effective. That's a lot.
Like there's a lot of power users just
run like six a day.
>> Yeah. And it's very quickly overnight
became like I think when when sonnet 4
and opus 4 came out I think anthropic
was probably serving 10% of their
inference or 20% of their inference to
cloud code and it probably jumped up to
like 50%. Like I think the the heaviest
like per token users are definitely
going to be the the cloud code people
who are like
>> running 10 in parallel
>> for everything. you what?
>> While this is running, the next thing is
like first thing that you'll notice is
once this thing is actually done
running, we're just going to have a
bunch of JSON files. JSON files are
garbage. They're not very useful at all
because like when I go look at them, I
won't be able to do anything. So, let's
go do something else now.
Please don't [ __ ] me cursor.
Let's
>> new chat.
table
stream. Is it stream lit? I don't know
what it is.
>> Yep. Yep. Streamlit should work. It's
pretty good at stream lit.
Yeah.
Oh, what the [ __ ] did it do? Cloud Code
did some stuff.
>> So, it's editing the JSON files for you.
>> Okay. Made made one file for me for test
and married gun. Cool.
Okay. It's got two files that I think
are mostly good.
Uh this is the last one. Burning any
foul
and I don't want to touch this file. I'm
kind of scared. So I'm going to let it
do its thing.
>> And because I deleted all the code, I
became super cautious right away because
I don't trust this
>> one thing.
Okay,
>> I think we're almost done. Um,
all right, let's just go run this really
fast. Um, and the first thing I'll do is
I'll notice that you what you'll notice
is like um the first thing you'll notice
is I don't actually trust whether the AI
thing is going to work or not. I don't
know if the cloud code generated code is
good.
This is the only thing I hate about
cloud code VS code. I can't hide it. Um,
so I'm actually not going to run the
code. I'm just going to run it like
this. Not say what it is.
>> Just going to make sure it kind of
compiles and works
>> exactly.
That work.
>> Uh, you had some pyantic error.
I think I run I'm running the wrong
test. There we go. That one worked. And
then email structure and then um
burning.
>> So what are those names again? What is
married guan burning guinea fo?
>> They're just like the two test names
that I had.
>> Yeah. when you when you pull tests from
the BAML console, it just makes up a
like random string for you.
>> Adjective animal. I think
>> it doesn't really matter. Um, but now
that I have the test, I can go run this.
And this will run. And while this is
doing this, I will also do that make the
results.
Then I'm going to run this. Okay, while
this is running, I'm now going to start
another cloud code test.
Um, I got scared by his cursor, so I
don't think I'll use it anymore. Um,
update the app to be a Streamlit app
that renders the result
as they come in
for each uh variant.
Um,
for each variant. Um, cool.
and see what it does. And the first
thing I'm going really want to do is I
just want to like vibe code a somewhat
decent UI so I can actually just iterate
because if I can't actually see my
results like
you'll notice in here uh email draft is
not JSON serializable because I I'm dumb
model
is what I should have done. Um and that
would produce a dict object that would
do everything. Do we do mode equals JSON
because it will you need it to convert
the time stamps if there's any time
stamps? Yeah. So,
>> thank you.
>> Let it run again.
>> I dump a lot of JSON in my day by let me
tell you.
>> I can see that. So, like this is like
one of the few things like this is why
it's just really good to not like go all
out on your emails and wait the whole
time for everything because if you do
that, you'll just get stuck. Um, sure,
why not?
I'll let it generate the screen app and
then it's going to go use this function
to go run run the unit test.
And once this thing is done it, as you
can see over here, it dumped out a bunch
of stuff.
And I can actually go look at each of
these and see how well they do. Uh, but
as you can see, it's actually going to
be hard for me to go read all this. So,
um, yes.
>> Oh, wow. Oh yeah, the JSON Unicode
serialized emojis is atrocious.
>> Yep, exactly.
UV run sync.
I don't actually know how to run a
Streamlit app. Uh, but I've run it a few
times, so I always have to look at how
to go do it.
>> I think you just UV run it.
>> Oh, UVX streamllet run.
Oh, yeah. There you go.
>> There you go. Um, so it actually lets
you select test as you're going to it.
Let's just select model and then I can
just run the evals.
>> So you have this yeah you have this um
pantic issue
>> where whatever whatever your test data
is like missing certain fields
>> because of this stupid thing. Uh let me
>> just paste it into cloud.
>> No no this one is like the wrong test
case that's why.
>> Okay.
Uh, it was called
>> search for email structure.
>> There you go.
>> Nice.
>> Oh, it just loads them in.
>> Yeah, your input JSON just paste that
error in the cloud.
>> That is also a good idea.
No, just put Yeah. Okay.
>> Maybe I give it too much context. Um, it
is running though and it is definitely
running something. Um,
>> yeah.
>> And it's running to like JSON
serializable
errors. Um, and then I just have to go
fix that one error which is
JSON.
>> It's it's off track.
Yeah. Okay. Good. Here we go.
if this is done. I usually do this in
TypeScript. I thought I'd do it in
Python today and I think that was a
mistake. Um,
and the reason I use TypeScript for
everyone else's context of why I prefer
to go do that is because what I really
want is I want a quick React app that I
can just like run a simple system in and
just see what's happening.
>> What Why don't you Why don't you push
what you have because I'll I can I can
kind of show show off how we might
quickly translate this to to TypeScript.
>> Let's do it.
Well, let me see if it's running yet.
One last thing and then if this runs and
I think we're good.
Dex, could you just also talk talk out
aloud when you're doing some of the
translation work because some of us
don't really know TypeScript that well.
>> Uh, I mean, I'll ask Claude to talk out
loud.
>> That would be great. Whatever works.
>> It's going to be very verbose. Uh, so we
might have to skim it, but I'll I'll
paste I can paste the trace in or
whatever.
>> Y'all can read it later.
The hard part about all this systems, as
many of you can see, is the hard part is
actually not the AI part. It's actually
building the infra so you can actually
go render everything. Okay. Well, this
isn't really working. So, I'm going to
I'm going to change I'm going to change
trajectories.
And instead of the app doing that, just
load the just make a streamlit app that
loads the data from the
results
directory and renders it. I gave up. Um,
I'm going to do a simpler thing and this
is like just get more guaranteed to be
good. Uh, I'm just going to load the
data from the results gener uh,
directory and just like render it and
then see what happens because I think
I'm just going to have way more
likelihood of success in that scenario.
>> Oh yeah, that works.
>> Yes. Uh, and that's a simpler way to go
about it. While I'm doing this, I
realize a couple more things. Uh, the
model name over here is going to have an
escape slash. So, I need to go unescape
that. Uh, unescaped
model.
Perfect.
>> I'm going to go deal with this. Uh, show
that off. Um,
go deal with this. Um,
uh,
I'm going to make that directory import
OS
and then UV.
This should in theory be a lot more
reliable.
if this app load. And now I can go see
it. And like really what I want to go do
is I literally just want to see these
side by side and just go read it because
that is the only true way that I can
actually eval them.
Uh and I just have to go build this. And
if I don't build this UI, no matter what
I no matter what I do, it won't be good.
And the first thing you can notice when
I build this UI is like I can
immediately see that see that one of
them is just longer than the other. It's
like a really quick glance thing that I
can get without reading it.
And I can see one of them includes bold
text, the other one doesn't. For better
or for worse, it doesn't really matter.
But the fact is like the UI based vibe
eval system that we build here is just
going to be a lot better than anything
else that we could do manually. So if I
go ahead and we'll do this again. Um,
u
main.py. We'll run this. And then I
think
what did I do?
email structure. Did I delete the wrong
one? Oh,
uh, which one do I want? I don't want
married one email structure.
Um, structure. Yeah.
If I go ahead and run this, it's going
to go ahead and produce a bunch of tests
for me really fast while it goes to run.
And then it should have a new directory
structure here to make my life slightly
easier when I go do this. Change
structure
to be
not allow JSON and then it dump stuff in
there. So I'll just run this
and then this should be able to run the
stream app.
and then be able to read from it.
And now you'll see I have a lot more
test in here. I have an optics on it and
openi as well that it wasn't reading
before because of the directory
structure. And like one of the most
practical things that I think a lot of
people under underlook when they build
these eval systems is the amount of work
that you have to put into actually like
building out all this like infra tooling
is surprisingly large. It's way more
than I ever expected. And this is the
same kind of work. If you go talk to any
data scientist, go talk to any machine
learning person that was doing it before
the LLM era, what they'll tell you is
90% of the job is not training the
model. 90% of the job is getting the
data in the right shape so you can make
the right decisions. And that is so
annoying. But that problem doesn't
magically go away when you work with LM.
It's just something you have to do very
very frequently. So in this
>> and this is why people talk about how
important eval are. And like when we did
the episode with Brian, he's like, I'll
share the code. I'll share the prompts.
The only thing I will not show on screen
is the evals because that's the part
that takes the most work and the most
thought and it is about knowing your
problem. And I think as we get to this
world where it's like more and more code
is written by AI and more and more
software can be trivially repro like if
you wanted to build a copy of VS code
you could do that with AI. There are
like techniques and processes where you
can take large complex software as long
as everything is documented. You can
build specs and plans to reproduce any
existing piece of software. And so the
real moat is this is like taste and
knowing what your users want and having
like hard-coded like results of looking
at stuff and deciding what good looks
like because then you can then you can
iterate on your stuff and then you can
learn and then you can keep making the
software better.
>> And even over here like think about how
complicated it is for me to actually
like go build this out. Like I can't
actually analyze emails like this. Like
this is not a good readable format. So
what I really want is I want A and B for
every test case. So I can see for every
test case I want to just swap out random
models. So I'm going to tell Gemini to
do I'm going to tell it to do that
instead of showing every model for every
test case
for a for a given
test case. I want to side by side drop
downs.
>> All right. After this I'm going to make
a commit and push and I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna practice uh I'm gonna
So I can see the So I can see side by
side of model versus model
what does that and this is just a really
important thing because like the thing
that I actually would want to build here
is not even like an evaluate. What I
really want to build is infra where my
team can go eval this stuff very
quickly. You can think of it like
building any sort of internal tooling
that you would be building for your own
company. And you have to again what
we're trying to do here is decide what
the goal of this email is. And the goal
of this email is I want to know what
email is better. I'm going to send this
out to like a bunch of people.
And like now I can go do this. And it
becomes really easy for me to go see
this. Like okay, let me swap this out
and see how well this works. Which one
do I like better?
>> Oh, this is better. Yeah, this is great.
>> And like now we can quickly see which
one we like. Um, these look almost the
same. Are they the same? No, this is my
Gemini. So, this is Flash. This is uh
this is um uh the better pro. And it
seems like Flash almost got everything
right, but it forgot about the next
session. So, like, okay, clear. Flash is
definitely a loser. Let me just move on
to the next one and go on. But you
notice something here. I did this super
manually. If I'm sharing this with my
team, I need to add a new feature to my
Eval dashboard, which is a thing where I
can leave my notes in here. Now, I
that's another thing I have to go build.
Another thing that I want to build is
like just like really quickly like
invalidate this and just say like Flash
is bad. So I might want to build like an
X. So I can just click X over here and
like remind myself that I've already
seen Flash compared to Gemini. And
there's all sorts of systems you can
build along the way here to just decide
which one is better. Same thing here.
Like this one just doesn't like it. This
one I guess made it a lot shorter which
could be better. One, two, three. You
got this one. It dropped one of the
bullet points which might be fine. I
don't really care. So, if I was okay
with this and anthropic sonnet would be
like seems okay. And GT4 Mini, I don't
really like this one. This one literally
just made a giant blob of text and
that's not what we want to send out. So,
this becomes immediately invalidated.
So, I'm like, "Okay, cool. I'm
>> I like the Borro mini one. It's like got
a little bit of like a Hemingway vibe
where it's just like lots of little
short sentences."
>> Dude, I hate this. But that's You can
see how we just disagree on this.
>> Yeah. But we need to be able to quickly
evaluate this in the previous
>> but now okay one more feed lap back loop
I want to do like go change the prompt
now and then rerun this and like this
shows how you can iterate on you like
use this as a system to iterate like
because it's not just on like which
one's better across the model but it's
like okay now let's change it let's see
how it changes all the models and how
all the models perform.
>> Exactly. And then the other thing you're
going to run into if we change the
prompt is now you need to previous
compare the previous version of the
prompt against this part. So now we have
three dimensions. We're comparing
against the model, the version, and the
model at the same time. So, and there's
no, and a lot of people will try and
sell you like, hey, I have the perfect
UI for you. We're going to solve all
your problems. The fact of the matter is
there's no perfect UI to be completely
honest. For seeing an email, this is
probably a better UI than like a
dashboard that just shows you JSON. I
don't want to see the JSON. I want to
see something that looks like an email
and reads like an email and renders the
markdown. for rendering coordinates on
an image. I want to see the actual image
with a box rod around the coordinates of
the image
>> and every single thing you have to do is
bespoke and unique. So, you just have to
do the work to go do this and like vibe
code it like we did over here. BJ's got
a question or like
>> no just an afterthought that you could
split the entire email body like we did
earlier uh in multiple like an
introduction paragraph and you know a
final
>> uh like call to action or whatever and
then pass them like evaluate them
whatever then you can actually it's not
it's no longer just a body anymore but
you have multiple segments to work with
with different bodies again. So you're
dissecting the problem into smaller
problems basically.
>> Exactly. And then the other thing that
you could end up doing is even though
you dissect it into smaller problems,
you could still assemble it from the
eval perspective as one big thing.
So from the eval perspective, it looks
like the big thing. And now we can build
small tooling. So like for example, I'll
show you something cool. Uh LMS tend to
Sorry, Dex. I'll I'll push it over in
one second. I really
>> No, you're good. I I think at this point
we can we can wrap it up soon and go to
questions. And I just all the activity
in the chat is telling me like let's do
our next episode on context engineering
with with uh with coding CLIs. I think
that's a great topic. LMS tend to
produce uh things like m dashes
and hyperboles.
um build a detector
for that in the UI by highlighting
LME
stuff. So I can go build this uh I can
just like add it to the UI where one of
the things it's going to do is just
highlight a bunch of stuff for me and
like if I go look at the diff of what's
going to generate. Did I miss it? No, I
didn't. Cool.
>> This is interesting. Okay. Oh, you it's
making it's using a reax to detect
things that look like LME.
>> Yeah. And I think that's okay. We don't
need it to be perfect. Um we just need
to be good enough.
>> That's actually a dope feature. Um
>> Exactly. content generation,
>> right?
>> Will you flip back to the UI before this
gets I just want to grab a screenshot
real quick for the for the episode.
>> Perfect. Okay. And then we can show
another one once it has the LM
detectors.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. It better put absolutely and
you're absolutely right in that reax.
>> Um
>> certainly
[Laughter]
>> that's funny.
>> Uh Sylvia's got a question.
>> So like it's put a bunch of stuff in
here. It's like uh undoubtedly been
credibly like I don't even know what
that means. Sure. What
>> comprehensive comprehensive needs to be
>> the back slashb is the it is beginning
of the word the word.
>> Sorry I'm dumb. Yes. Uh yes. Uh, as you
can see, um, I spend very little time
writing Reax. Thank goodness for that.
>> Yeah, Viob replaced all his Reaxes with
40 Mini like six years ago.
>> 40 Mini is amazing at Reax.
And like boom, now we can just see this
right away. And you can see how like I
just improved the Eval system really
fast without doing too much work.
>> Yeah. And this is what actually um I
forget. I think it was Sarah Cat and
Zarah at Amplify Partners posted this
like a year ago like talked to a 100 AI
founders and one of her big takeaways is
like the eval harness is basically just
like any other test system. It's quite
easy to build and the actual value in
eval is generating the data of like
what's good and what's not so that you
can continue to improve
>> trying to solve a problem using so uh VJ
I I think the interesting thing about
this is like what I'm not trying to do
is I'm not trying to solve the problem
of saying that this is perfect what I'm
trying to do with this goal the reason I
even came up with this UI is not because
I think this is perfect but what I
really want to do is I just want the
user who's evaluing to quickly see
certain things
and I'm like okay like cuz if I scan
this I might not even notice that an M
dash existed here but like I don't know
if you go on Reddit if you go anywhere
you'll often see people now complaining
about like a m dashes post I just ignore
them because they're all AI generated
>> and some people auto filter emails that
have m dashes in them and there's all
sorts of these risks that are now
happening because of AI generated
behavior. So, I want to go and like uh
uh like uh flag for that quickly.
>> Um
>> that's really sad because some of us
like m dashes.
>> I love
>> I do too. And now I explicitly remove
them because like I'm in a lot of like
founder groups and just general. I've
talked to a lot of folks and like most
people remove them.
>> OM has been prompt or has been poisoning
my training data with M dashes.
Yeah, I think actually like the trick is
like uh just like we did on Twitter in
2013 uh intentional typos. And I've I've
been using M dashes for 10 years, but
I've always used them wrong. People tell
me that's the wrong way to use an M
dash. And I'm like, no, this is how I
use M dashes. So, there's my trick. You
can keep your M dash as long as you use
it wrong. Like, put spaces around it.
The correct way to use an M dash is to
have it like touch both words with no
spaces around it. But if you put spaces
around it, no one every you can you can
prove, hey, that's not an LLM cuz I did
it wrong.
>> I do that all the time. That's my human.
>> I feel like people that think that
people don't know how to use M dashes
and that only agents do probably don't
know the proper usage of M dashes.
>> Yeah.
>> Sad question.
>> I'm gonna turn this into an email really
fast.
>> Yeah. So I had just wanted to summarize
what VIP was saying earlier where it
seems like evaluation tooling is
incredibly specific to the definition of
accuracy and the actual business problem
that the LLM is being used to solve and
thus it cannot be it has to be bespoke.
>> doesn't have to be bespoke, but it's
easy to do it bespoke and then you have
full flexibility. This is kind of
exactly how uh shad CN works where it's
like scaffold out the core of it that is
like basic best practices, but then you
can change everything you want. And now
the code is really cheap. I think in
general it's like if you have the
patterns or the outline or you have a
template that you can use for this stuff
then um and then you customize it with a
vibe coding tool or something like that.
I think that's probably right. Um there
are for certain very like if you are
drawing bounding boxes on images there
are tools that will do it better and
more completely than whatever you can
vibe code in an hour for sure. If your
use case is super generic, but also like
if you're building evals for a super
generic use case, you're probably
already cooked because that shit's been
around for five years.
>> Exactly. And like you'll notice what I
just did really fast because I built
this eval dashboard. I did something. I
literally added a new model called Chad
GBT really quickly where I literally
just went to CHBT, generated the same
JSON. Um, and I'm just going to have it
go through that again
and I will generate for this one as
well.
I'll go render this. And I'm This isn't
even me doing this manual. I just went
to ChatGpt, did this uh straight up. I
just asked to do zero shot do the model.
And what I want to do now is I can go
here in theory. I should see ChatG pop
up and I can just like compare it. We
know that we like my Gemini Smart and
then we know that we have a new one
called Chat GT. So you can just like
compare it
and like the first thing you'll notice
is just like yeah there's just a lot
more m dashes right away in chat GBT and
this is without me having to read it.
It's a lot shorter. It's a lot different
and this one reads a little bit more AI
generated. If someone saw this one they
wouldn't see that. But like what I'm
trying to do in Eval is just like really
quickly detect it and see what happens.
And I'm trying to make life easier for
the developer so that the person that's
actually building the pipeline can
quickly decide is chatt better or not in
my use case.
And if you build a good framework, then
ideally what you'll have is you'll
slowly make this system better and
better and better for this part of your
pipeline.
>> And you will likely not end up with just
one of these systems. You'll end up with
tons of these systems
>> because you'll have Go ahead.
>> Sorry, I was going to say and the one
one of the dimensions that we're not
tracking here is the actual prompt
itself. Like you could actually take
five models, five prompts, and then
generate what is it 25 outputs and then
have a one-on-one like voting system and
just have people go through which one is
better, which one is better until you
get to the best one and then that's how
you kind of decide what to develop on.
>> Exactly. And the real problem here that
everyone runs into from my experience is
just the fact that like these are
complex multi-dimensional problems.
You're you're indexing on the test case.
You're indexing on the model. You're
indexing on the prompt. You're indexing
on any such variety of stuff.
>> Which episode are we doing the email
for? All that stuff could be variables.
>> Exactly. Right. So like all that stuff
just takes time to go build out and
sadly there's no shortcut and the best
thing you can do is like well I mean we
do have a shortcut which is you use LM
to generate all the code so you don't
have to build it. And we spend we went
from nothing to fully running the test
suite to actually viewing multiple
models to actually having a UI that we
can go eval stuff on in less than an
hour.
>> And we deleted all the code once.
>> And yeah, and we deleted all the code
once. Um
stuff is really fast now. You just have
to go like go do and this is going to be
way faster than like any automated LM
evalu.
And it's not that it's naturally going
to be better. It's just that I don't
have a clear definition for what a great
email is. So I can put LM as judge, but
like I don't even know what's going to
judge him. Like it's not going to be
very helpful right now for this.
>> Right. You need to get your judge prompt
really well and eval that separately.
>> Exactly. Exactly. And if I were doing
LMS as judge, what I would do here is
I'd write another prompt to go and eval
the email at the very end here to say,
"How is this one good?" And then I'd
literally write the annotation here of
what the judge says. And then I can eval
the judge prompt while evaling the main
prompt. And it becomes this huge meta
problem along the way. VJ you had a
question.
>> I just have an afterthought again. Uh
because we are discussing evaluating uh
the structure of emails. Naturally since
we are trying to develop the entire uh
email structure um recently we did one
implementation of outbound uh email uh
like email sales and we noticed that for
example we were targeting uh executives
for a small segment and none of these
executives actually read their emails.
It was it was LLMs doing their emails.
So we sat and you know evaluated all of
these complex systems like you just
mentioned. Turns out they don't care. So
they wanted it in a particular structure
in a particular format without uh
complex uh URLs or images or whatever.
So the point is I think it's not just
about uh getting the structure right but
it is about actually understanding the
entire end to-end use case and see how
this brings impact to the business
because we need to keep that in
perspective as well at end of the day
that that outcome is what is uh
delivering value and not uh this
particular outcome does that make sense
>> I think that's a great way to put it
>> yeah and like like I I think what I
would do here is just like if I were
building this out more holistically like
there's small checks that I would build.
For example, how many of the links here
are made up versus valid.
>> Yeah, that can be your like runtime
guards, right? Is like go try to fetch
every link and make sure that it
actually returns a 200 or whatever.
>> Yeah. Or I could just do that only in my
evalu. I don't actually have to go do it
everywhere. I can just purely do in my
evalu.
>> Yeah.
>> I can go validate that like there's no
placeholders like this one. Like if
there's like a word with like a bracket
with like the word here on it, I can go
detect that and detect placeholders
because that seems to be a pretty common
pattern
>> and there's like any such thing that I
could go build slowly over time to make
the system as good as I need it to be. I
think Sylvia had a question a while ago.
I don't know if the question still
exists.
>> I think it was addressed.
>> Okay, awesome.
Um, with that, any other questions
before I we get to show off something
really freaking cool today?
>> All right, this will be your teaser
preview for the next. You got to come in
and push this though.
>> Okay, let me push it.
Uh, made some change added. Uh, Eval
system. Let me make sure I did not
accidentally check in my file. Yes, for
comparing models plus test cases.
We're not going to be able to go deep on
this because we don't have time, but
this will be your teaser for next week.
And I think yeah, next week it seems
like there's a ton of interest in doing
um doing like a how do we do context
engineering for coding agents like cloud
code and Gemini CLI and stuff like that.
>> I pushed um I will let you screen share.
I thought this is the coolest thing I've
ever seen. Um I'll give a little primer
um because I'm usually very very suspect
on most things. Um, but like vibe coding
is kind of annoying. Um, but I think
vibe coding is a different kind of
coding than cursor or anything else is.
And like I think when I first met
someone that was trying to go do this, I
was just like, ah, cursor just feels
wrong. And we saw an examples of it
today. Like what I'm really trying to do
is I'm not really writing code. I'm
watching the code.
And like that showed me something that
was really freaking cool. uh which is
what does an ID look like if your
primary incentive
is to like watch the code not write the
code yourself.
Is that a good description Dex?
>> Yeah, I think that's right.
Um so this is kind of our tool for
multipplexing cloud codes. This is open
source. We can go deeper next week, but
this is a system that lets you run lots
of cloud codes in parallel. Um
so I can say start bootstrapping a new
Nex.js JS app.
So I have one claude running and doing
the bootstrapping. I have another claude
building a plan to research the current
codebase and find the streamlet app and
go through all of this. Um let's see we
are tracking the to-dos here. Um but
basically the interesting thing here is
not like hey there's a UI on cloud code
that's a little bit nicer. The
interesting thing here is really like
the process that we use for uh prompting
Claude to do this like continual
compacting markdown and doing context
engineering by using sub agents to
research and fetch things and sort of
like I think um I forget the source
graph um CTO talked about this at AI
engineer which is like the skill of
wielding coding agents. If you just
shout at claude what you want, you're
not going to get great results.
Um, but if you are able to kind of wield
the agent, well, then um, all right.
See, this is this one's not going to
work because it's going to have to do
uh, a bunch of shell things. Um, so
there's still certain things that we do,
but essentially like what we what we've
been doing a lot at Human Layer lately
is basically like closing the editor.
Um,
and what we do have is uh
we we do a lot of like reading
implementation plans. Um, and so this is
what we're editing right now is like
markdown files that talk about the code
and how it's going to change because if
you can get this right, then the
implementation is always really really
clean. And so we spend way more time
reviewing and like nitpicking these
implementation plans. that talk about
what the architecture is going to be
than we do actually um
nitpick like I barely review code
anymore and like I said I haven't opened
a file in an editor in like a month
because we mostly just look at these
plans and so everything we're doing is
open source we'll keep the specs is the
thing that we're not publishing just yet
um because that's the valuable thing
because if an AI agent is good and
you're prompting it right then you can
take any spec and turn it into working
code um
>> so anyways that's uh That's a little
preview. Um, if you're interested in
playing with this, um, happy to I'll
I'll throw a link in the in the email.
There's we have a weight list sign up.
Um, especially if you like superhuman or
you like using Vim mode and you hate
touching the mouse. Um, this is a really
fun set of tools that we've been messing
with and uh, curious to see what people
think.
>> Questions, thoughts. Vib, what do you
want? What do you want to see here? I
mean number one thing I saw is like look
the infrastructure for me of like
setting up git work trees and all this
other stuff is just annoying and like
this you just want something that kind
of does that for you. That's why I found
it personally kind of interesting.
>> Oh the work tree stuff. Yeah, we should
talk about we can talk about work trees
next week too. Um we haven't built in
work tree support for this yet but um we
have a bunch of prompts that make it
pretty easy to create work trees for all
this. Um but
>> yeah, it'll be fun. I think like
multipplexing and like five coding in
general has been really good. Maybe I'll
get someone else from my team to show up
as well who's I think is a much better
vibe coder than I am. As we all
discovered, I delete my code way more
often by accident. Um, but I'll show
that off in a bit.
Um, with that, um, I think that's it for
today's episode. Unless someone's got
one last question. Uh, we'll take one
more if there is one. Otherwise, we're
going to log off and then we'll come
back next week where we'll talk about
actually like what the full vibe coding
workflow is for like building agents.
Yeah, we're going to make all of you
99.9th percentile vibe coders. It's
going to be it's going to be a good
time. And if anyone has a cool vibe
coding workflow that you want to share
next week, like think about it and we
can maybe have people do like one to two
minute demos.
>> Sorry, was there a question?
>> Oh, I was just saying I'm not trying to
be a 99th percentile vibe coder yet. I
feel like I got to be a 99th percentile
coder first.
Uh a lot of people are skipping that
part.
>> People I think the way I I I was also
very skeptical to be completely honest
of that. But like the thing that has
changed my perspective is like my gut
instinct is not to use AI. And I think
the part of the reason is like one I'm a
I feel like I'm a very efficient
developer. So I write code generally
fast. two, I kind of feel like AI I was
like I have this natural bias because
I'm still thinking about GPT35 and GPT4
sometimes about the limits of today's
models and I'm like ah yeah I can't do
that but what I've been trying to do now
is I have a new policy which is like for
any feature I implement I spend 10
minutes on clog or cursor or something
like that and after that what I end up
doing is at the end of 10 minutes I
either decide do I think I'll finish
this task in 30 minutes or not if the
answer is no then and I go back to
coding. If the answer is yes, I stay
vibe coding. And it has been a really
good mental model for me to get over.
>> You're doing something that I think is
really important, which is Jeff Huntley
calls deliberate intentional practice.
>> Yeah. And it's just like I have to I
have to muscle my way to do this.
>> The reason why I've been so skeptical is
because I've been like coding for less
than a year and a half at this point. So
I'm just like I really want good
foundations.
>> Yeah. Yeah. the the maybe I like I said
it's hard to know. I don't know what's
best or what's wrong, but I'm just
sharing my practice. But we'll talk
about the stuff a lot more and like
other things that we've been having the
team do uh to get better at like
shipping code faster along the way.
>> But that's the idea is like it's it's
it's good to just try it for I actually
really like what you just said by Bob is
like let me try it for 10 minutes a day
before I go start to do my old thing.
And that's like
>> 10 minutes a feature not 10 minutes a
day
>> if you are going to learn anything. Um,
and the LM is essentially a very complex
instrument and we all need to learn to
play it. And the problem is is that they
ship a new version of the instrument
every month and you got to learn to play
that one too. Um, but I think that's the
future is going to look a lot like um
something that is a little more art than
science and something that is a lot more
feel than than concrete. But if you can
stay on the bleeding edge of of of what
the best in class looks like in that
world, uh you're gonna be you're gonna
reap rewards.
>> Anyway, we'll chat more about this next
week. Um for this week, uh that's it. We
talked about how to evalu
dashboards as you build them. Post
screenshots conversations always live on
the Discord if you guys would like or
send us an email.
>> Awesome. Super fun. Thanks. Bye, Bob.
Thanks everybody.
>> Bye everyone. owned by Dex.